in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some leaping lizards
track down why their bandwidth was off
in the weeds will we catch what's
bugging them stay tuned to find out
I got a nice call from the gecko
protocol team a b2b company offering a
custom lightweight networking protocol
built for gaming and other real-time
graphic systems their team was seeing
lower than expected throughput for their
back-end machines which are responsible
for transferring and transcoding large
video and graphics files their
architecture worked a little something
like this a client will push about 2
terabytes of data to cloud storage at
the same time it kicks off work request
to a front-end which leverages a TCP
load balancer to spin up a bunch of
compute engine instances in a single
region to feed on that data talk between
each other and get the work done
most of this was working as expected
however the gecko protocol group was
concerned about VM to VM throughput
where they were only seeing about 1.5
gigabit per second max connections I
duplicated their setup on my side which
involves a bunch of one CPU machines in
a single region and ran iperf on them
the result was about 1.9 five gigabits
per second which was much higher than
what gecko protocol was seeing now I
knew from experience that for high
bandwidth systems they were obviously
using too small machine for those
efforts since networking throughput is
related to core count bumping it up to
about 16 CPU machine in the US central
one region I was able to get about
fifteen point nine gigabits per second
obviously much better however when the
gecko protocol team switched over to
this configuration they didn't see the
same result they only ended up at about
one point six gigabits per second after
about twenty minutes of a video chat
trying to get our configurations
identical the solution smacked us right
in the face
the problem was that their team was
testing the connection to the external
IP of the server while I was testing on
the internal IP see if two machines are
communicating using their internal IPs
then they can send traffic on Google's
private Internet which is super fast
using the public IP however forces the
data packet to get pushed to the public
Internet before coming back to the
machine aka not the fastest when we
switched over their configuration to use
the internal IPS with the larger machine
set up the bandwidth went through the
roof fifteen point nine gigabits per
second for gecko protocol this small
debugging session resulted in their
video and graphics data transfer rate
improving
by about 14x for more great cloud
content subscribe to the Google cloud
YouTube channel and stay up to date with
other cloud performance Atlas video
content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts